In fact, one thing that Trump said was just insane, dude.
And now he's trying to act like it was sarcasm,
which is the best disinfect dent,
uh, Trump dude,
the guy's such a goofball and he says I was sarcastic. And he's just like,
and it's just a certain not sarcastic dude, dude, dude. Cool.
It's so cool to say, dude, did you know that instead of dude?
Um, now this is one of those YouTube videos. Let's check this out.
This is one of those YouTube videos that when I check it,
it won't it'll I'll have it and it won't have the actual YouTube video.
It'll have somebody talking about the UWC. There we go. It looks like,
and the government, who's this guy to protect us. What's this guy's name again?
Testing. He turned his attention with the magic pill. He turned the magic pill.
It couldn't look more like you sounds.
And that guy who the white house is scrambling to mitigate president Trump's
suggestion that objecting or consuming something that should not be as consumed
or injected under any circumstances. Wow.
Chris Hayes points out as a part of pattern,
which was like a magic bullet to save him. And so Chris Hayes is the guy,
Chris Hayes looks like the guy
who brings, uh,
one piece of candy and eats it in front of the class. And everyone's like,
is there any for anyone else? And he goes, and he's,
he secretly thinks that your mom, you know, your mom's don't love you. Um,
but when Trump says the thing about the I would make the economy and the stock
market, all right, I don't want to risk.
I want to obviously see Trump saying this. I don't know.
Whether it's an ultraviolet or supposing.
We hit the body with a tremendous, uh,
whether it's ultraviolet or just very powerful light.
And I think you said that has Imma check, but you're going to test it.
And then I said, supposing, you've brought the light inside the button,
which you can do either through the skin or in some other way.
And I think you said, you're going to test that too. So that was interesting.
And then I see the disinfectant knocks it out in a minute,
one minute. And is there a way we can do something like that?
She's not going to have
injections inside or most of cleaning cause you see it gets in the lungs and
it does a tremendous number of along. So it'd be interesting to check that.
Very interesting.
It would actually be very interesting to check that it would be so interesting
to inject somebody with Lysol, but you know what?
Let's not do it because can't do that because it's not medical supply and also
injecting it. It would be, it goes on the lungs was my favorite part.
It goes on the lungs. First of all, it would go in the lungs.
It goes on the lungs. This guys watched too many Avenger movies.
We just put an ultraviolet light and yeah, I, I know, I understand.
I understand what he meant to it. Okay.
I understand about the ultraviolet light and all the, but guess what?
I'm not a scientist also dead work. Okay. Can't wait for the comments.
Oh, did you just stop talking about politics?
You obviously don't know what you're talking about. No.
I don't know what I'm talking about. Okay. But the thing is,
I'm not president, I'm not a shocker potatoes dude.
Uh, yeah. And the lady with nine scars,
this lady is always looking like she just got twisted up in some curtains and it
was like, but I'm late for the briefing and then ran.
And he's talking about how you can just inject
the and like, let me tell you something to do with my, uh, what do you call it?
My, uh, radar for sarcasm. My radar is pretty good. You know, I'm a,
I'm a, I'm a comedian. I literally almost said I'm a computer.
And if I did that, I would've just left. I would've left.
I would've drove out of my house and I would have,
you wouldn't have seen me for a long, long time. All right.
Because I would've just given up on life. I would've cried.
I would've just listened to that.
[inaudible] funny face is Sharvin bass is learnin.
Vase is while I was driving and his kid is carrying a funny furniture for some
reason. I think the word funny is in that song so many times. Um, but uh,
I would have been crying mad world,
mad whirl. Well, if I said computer instead of comedian, now,
now boys, I'm a computer. Cute. All.
I'm a computer like that old judge out thing that went viral. But anyway,
I'm a comedian. I am. I'm pretty good at understanding what, what a, uh,
sarcasm is. And also a president don't be sarcastic.
Number one, job. Be sarcastic fire man. Number two, president. Okay.
Hey, get out. The building's burning. Oh my God. Really psych does.
It's the same thing. If you're the president inject Lysol, you are kidding.
Well, 18 people died from doing it because you're the leader of the free world.
Anyway. Uh, shouldn't have done it. Why can't he just be like,
I don't know what I was talking about. I didn't mean to say it that way.
I know how it came off. Oops. Okay. Why doesn't he just do that?
Why doesn't he just do that? Everyone would be like, Oh, all right, well, yeah,
that was a goofy whatever, but he's like, well, I can't be wrong.
So I was, I was sarcastic, sarcastic dude.
Also I didn't do the motion. You know,
he should have done that if he was being sarcastic. Yeah, yeah.
Inject Lysol in your veins or [inaudible]
anyway, uh,
Biden got endorsed by Hillary Clinton, which is just like,
and he was just like I'm with her and he retweeted it. So Hey, uh, Biden,
you know, let's not,
let's not do that because that'll definitely make sure that you don't, um,
you don't, uh, you don't, when you understand what I'm saying,
Biden with that tongue swoop that
at tongue swoop that Trump retweeted the Geoff, the deep,
it's not a deep fake, I don't think.
But the Biden after he was talking about beef jerky, you probably did that.
Or some binal bring up anything, dude. Biden will bring up anything
fine. What are you going to do with the economy? You ever,
you ever put together a chair? Um, yeah. So,
uh, so yeah, so he's just like I'm with her and everyone goes like, Oh,
you like Hillary? Cool. Well then you don't believe in pizza gate.
You lost my vote. Um,
so yeah, so, so I don't know, but that thing was scary as.
And then people, and then I sent it to the group text and Nick Swardson said,
is that real? And I go, okay. I can't, you know, no,
it's not real. Cause he looks like a demon. Um,
but uh, yeah, so he was, uh,
he retweeted that and people were like up in arms,
dude labels are absolutely up in arms about this sticky that Trump
used and weaponized a deep fake the,
for you that you wouldn't think that the first person who weaponized the deep
fake is the president of
the United States of America. You'd imagine it would come from a
PO box that was out of, out of commission. But it comes from,
I saw something that said it you'd think it would come from this place,
but it came from 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue. Yeah, dude,
I understand people are real dumb. I understand people are so, so stupid.
Like you can't, you know,
That whole inciting a riot thing, but it's like,
if you're real stupid and you think that a, that, that Biden thing is real.
You're the first to go, bro.
You gotta get on the front line and just get a rat tat tat it up, dude,
fight for our country and get out, Pat it up. Um,